monsieur sébastien lecornu ministre d
outre-mer madame jacqueline gourault
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice madame
roselyne bachelot ministre de la culture
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame annick
girardin ministre de la mer madame
frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
monsieur julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
madame amélie de montchalin ministre de
la transformation et de la fonction
publique sont nommé ministre délégué
auprès du premier ministre monsieur marc
fesneau chargé des relations avec le
parlement et de la participation
citoyenne
madame elisabeth moreno chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la diversité et de l'égalité des
chances auprès du ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères monsieur
franck riester chargé du commerce
extérieur et de l'attractivité auprès de
la ministre de la transition écologique
madame emmanuelle wargon chargé du
logement
monsieur jean baptiste djebbari chargé
des transports
auprès du ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance monsieur
olivier du soft chargé des comptes
publics
madame agnès pannier renager chargé de
l'industrie monsieur alain griset chargé
des petites et moyennes entreprises
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
madame roxana maracineanu chargé des
sports auprès de la ministre des armées
madame geneviève darrieussecq chargée de
la mémoire et des anciens combattants
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
madame marlène schiappa chargé de la
citoyenneté auprès de la ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
madame brigitte klinkert chargé de
l'insertion auprès de la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires des relations
avec les collectivités territoriales
madame nadia est chargé de la ville
auprès du ministre des solidarités et de
la santé madame brigitte bourguignon
chargé de l'autonomie est nommé
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre monsieur gabriel attal
porte-parole du gouvernement le
président de la république réunira le
conseil des ministres avec l'ensemble
des membres du gouvernement ce mardi 7
juillet à 15 heures je vous remercie